Speaker 1: I want to spend just one moment
going through a few clips that are all of
Mypillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell. This
isn't really about Mike Lindell in particular,
but this is about the sort of psychosis that
seems to have afflicted so many on the right
over the last week as Republicans failed to win
winnable seats in the House, Senate and governor's
races. Republicans are going to take control
of the House. They will not have control of
the Senate. And they lost some key gubernatorial
races. Take a look at this. Mike Pillow was at Mar
a Lago yesterday for Donald Trump's announcement
for 2024. He is now saying, I have the proof.
Carrie Lake really won the governor's race in
Arizona. She didn't. I have the proof that Blake
Masters really won the Senate race in Arizona.
He did not. How long are they going to do this?
How long are they going to tell the exact same
stories for which they have no evidence? It seems
like it is years. Years. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: We bottom there absolutely
everything that was done in Arizona. We
called our court. And this going to just
doesn't happen this sphere for unraveling
ends and tens of thousands of cities that
are looking for a place to reach out, they're
going to do a sworn affidavit of what happened.
Speaker 1: Remember, affidavits are not
evidence. They can be accepted as claims
that are still evaluated like testimony.
Affidavits are not evidence. Strictly speaking.
Speaker 2: I don't think there's a judge in this
country that can say we need a new election down
there in Arizona.
Speaker 1: And now
can you imagine a new election in Arizona? There
is going to be no new election. Steve Bannon's
already talking about decertification
or prevention of certification. Again,
there's no such thing. Kerry League lost.
Blake Masters lost. More people voted for
their opponents. That's what happened.
Speaker 2: Just for Gary Lake. Remember,
they took Mark Benson's do. They took
Blake Masters. They were all stalled.
Speaker 1: And they were stalled.
They were stalled, folks.
Speaker 2: No matter what anyone says, we already
know this. We were watching it from the Edison
report. We were watching and Cyberlink and.
Speaker 1: Sibel, they were.
They saw it stalled. Sibel. Think of it.
Speaker 2: We are watching just blatantly
the citizens for watch. So you have imagine
having three different camera angles of a
crime. When you have a crime of this magnitude
committed, you can't certify this election. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Folks, this is part of why they
lost in 2022. I don't want to say that the
sole reason Republicans did so terribly was their
insistence on election denial. But to some degree,
certain candidates harping on it was stalled,
as pillow says, did not help them. This is now
a religion. It's not it's no longer. Well, we
think 2020 was stolen. No. Now it's we think
22 was stolen. We believe they're going to
steal 20, 24 unless we win, in which case we
zip our lips and shut our mouths. Here's another
clip of pillow losing the little bits that were
that are left of his mind. I guess as the Kerry
Lake results came in, this guy is very unwell.
Speaker 2: What she has then was an image.
All the images before they came in and
did the trusted build. So these are these
teams, these team of experts, cyber guys,
everything for seven months now. How about there
was a came out with the first report the second
part this is the one we've all been waiting for
because this shows actual machine manipulation.
It shows the it shows the manipulation
not just that they can be manipulated,
but that our 2020 election was deleted.
Speaker 1: He has no such evidence and he has
never presented it. It has been two years now.
Speaker 2: It's manipulated
all these things. And not just
that, but the also the election,
another election they had in in Colorado.
So you have two sets of proof there and.
Speaker 1: There is no.
Speaker 2: Proof. Try to
see because it's vindicated. It's here. It's
over. These guys are guilty. And and these are
when these when you see these are the credentials
these guys out, by the way, we put it up on free
speech exclusively. You can go there and view
this report and and the stuff that backs it up
where they got the stuff from and I looked for it.
Speaker 1: There is absolutely no proof there. You
know, if Mike Pillow came forward and said,
you know what? I was wrong. I don't have the
proof. I don't have it. And even if I suspect that
something was was amiss, I don't have any of the
proof I claim to have. I'm sorry. I'm sorry for
what I did. I would actually respect the guy to
some degree. Mike Pillow also yesterday at Mar a
Lago with the completely and obviously incorrect
claim that today Ron DeSantis would be endorsing
Trump for president. We're halfway through the
day more. And DeSantis has not done that.
Unidentified: Here we are live. It was only.
Speaker 2: Talking to almost all of them. They
asked me about Ron DeSantis running against Donald
Trump, and they said, after tonight, Ron will
just endorse him in the morning. You got him.
Why would you want to waste all the time, energy,
money and everything else? So very exciting here.
Speaker 1: Another one of Mike Pillows predictions
that obviously isn't coming true unless in the
next few hours, Ron DeSantis decides to come out
and endorse Trump for president. I don't believe
that's going to happen. And if you if you allow me
to bet on that, I'm not a betting man, but I would
bet on that. We are going to take a quick break,
make sure that you are following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show. All of these clips we played
are on our Instagram. After this short break,
we're going to look at polling. We're going
to look at the existing campaign for being
Trump's vice president. There's really
one person right now who's in the middle
of that campaign, and that's Marjorie
Taylor GREENE and so many other things.